People of the internet, RetroRaconteur here.
I’m just a dad who loves games and the stories
they tell.
For today’s video - whether you need a refresher
on confirmed Hogwarts Legacy details or if
you’re looking for news on the game for
the first time, wands at the ready.
Because here are 35 Hogwarts Legacy facts
we know for sure.
Hogwarts Legacy is being developed by Avalanche
Software - nope, not the Just Cause devs - the
Cars 3 devs.
In fact, this will be the longest Avalanche
has worked on a single title given that Cars
3 released all the way back in 2017.
The game is being developed as an open-world
action RPG
And it’s set in the late 1800s wizarding
world of Harry Potter.
As a result, we won’t be seeing Harry, Ron,
or Hermione make an appearance in the game.
That being said, the devs have confirmed we’ll
meet up with Gryffindor House ghost - Nearly
Headless Nick.
Fingers crossed we get Peeves as well.
We’ll also be traveling to familiar locations
including the Forbidden Forest and Hogsmeade
Village.
Players will also find new and unexpected
locations, characters, and story elements along the way.
Magical creatures will feature prominently
and a number of them have already been confirmed
including centaurs, goblins, graphorns, mooncalves,
spiders, trolls, and hippogriffs.
The official trailer even shows we’ll be able to
ride hippogriffs.
Cats and owls are also shown in the trailer,
although we don’t know for sure about toads just yet.
As for the more nefarious creatures, both
inferi and dementors will make an appearance.
There’s also this enormous dragon.
If you look carefully at the official wallpaper for the game - which you can download from
the Hogwarts Legacy website - you’ll be
able to spot fwoopers and an enormous acromantula
hidden in the forest.
JK Rowling is not directly involved in the
project, however, Hogwarts Legacy does plan to adhere
to the wizarding world lore set forth in the Harry Potter books.
Player choice will play a significant role
in the game with us having to choose if we want to be good or bad.
We’ll also be able to select companions
to aid and fight alongside us in our journey.
When it comes to schooling at Hogwarts, a lot of folks are wondering about the sorting ceremony.
It's already been confirmed that we'll be able to choose our house at the start of the game.
As for the day to day at Hogwarts, we’ll be mastering spells, brewing potions, and taming fantastic beasts.
There's an IMDB page that lists Jylian Petrie, Demetrious Daniels, Lawrence Kern, and Catherine Lonsdale among the cast for the game.
Julia Farino is another actress who had previously appeared on the page; however, it has since been removed.
At the time, it said she would be playing the characters of Cassandra Mason and Helen Thistlewood.
As far as the story goes, the main character
receives a late acceptance letter to Hogwarts
and will be on a journey to uncover a hidden
truth of the wizarding world.
Our character will also have a special ability to perceive and master ancient magic...whatever that means.
We’ll be able to customize our character
and also upgrade various talents, although
the specifics on this are still unknown.
Broomsticks and flying are shown in the trailer, although we don’t yet know for sure if quidditch will make an appearance.
Adrian Ropp is head of story on the project.
He has a wide-range of experiences with top companies like Pixar, Marvel, Disney, Lucasfilm and of course, WB.
A full trailer of the game leaked all the
way back in 2018 when reddit user VapethisBro
posted it online.
He claimed to have been a part of a mall survey
group that was shown a trailer for the game
and he somehow managed to get by without signing an NDA.
The leaked footage showed what appeared to be a dark, mature wizarding world game with one
particular scene that showed a group of goblins
meeting a rather gruesome fate.
Specific spells were also shown in that trailer, including lumos, alohomora, reparo, stupefy, expulso, and depulso.
It’s also worth noting that even though
it’s pretty clear this was a legit leak,
it still doesn’t mean we’ll see all of
these items in the final game.
Hogwarts Legacy was finally announced in an
official capacity with a trailer at the PS5
showcase event back in September of 2020.
The game was originally slated for a 2021 release date, but has since been delayed to the ever-nebulous, “2022.”
Avalanche has confirmed the game will appear on PC, PS4, PS5, Xbox One, as well as the Xbox Series S & X.
WB is publishing the game under the Portkey
games label, which is a label specifically
created for the Wizarding World of Harry Potter.
We also know they’re using the Unreal Engine
for the project
And although information has been scarce since the initial trailer, WarnerMedia’s CEO Jason
Kilar tweeted out 4 concept images back in
April of 2021, which showed the house crests,
a baby dragon, a garden gnome, and two graphorns in a small enclosure on what appear to be the Hogwarts grounds.
Also, one of the Avalanche devs who works on the sound design for the game did an interview
in May of 2021 where he answered some questions about the game.
The full interview actually included a variety of topics about game development, but there were also a few questions specifically about Hogwarts Legacy.
Unfortunately, the full interview was removed
from YouTube; however, I have a full break-down
of the video here on my channel if you’re
interested in knowing all the details.
You can check it out on the left side of your screen now and if you’re new here
and if you're new here and want to know more about Hogwarts Legacy, check out my full playlist on the right side of your screen now.
Also, you can find official sources for all
of these facts in the video description below.
As always, thank you all so much for watching,
I’ll talk to you again soon.